la première décision ça a été le Conseil
de politique nucléaire du 28 septembre
2012 qui annonce la fermeture de
Fessenheim à la fin de mon mandat fin
[Musique]
la question avant qu'elle ne soit posée
mais pourquoi fait scénario il y avait
plusieurs raisons
si on devait fermer une centrale pour en
ouvrir une autre en l'occurrence
Flamanville de plus grande dimension
d'ailleurs
la première c'était que l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire dans un avis du 3
février 2012 donc avant que je n'arrive
aux responsabilités
déclaré maître en œuvre qu'il fallait
mettre en œuvre de très importants
travaux pour pérenniser l'exploitation
de Fessenheim le deuxième argument
c'était que c'était la plus vieille de
nos centrales mais c'était pas le plus
décisif moi ce qui me paraissait le plus
essentiel c'était que nous pouvions
faire de fêteenheim alors que nous
savions que dans 10 ans dans 15 ans nous
aurions a fermé des centrales parce
qu'elles arrivaient au terme de leur vie
ils soient possibles sur le site de
Fessenheim d'en faire un centre de
recherche pour précisément la
prolongation des centrales et l'hôtel
est le démantèlement
d'où cette décision est le message de
modernisation peut-être
ainsi énoncer la plus vieille de nos
centrale était remplacée par la plus
moderne en l'occurrence le père de
flamonville mais c'était mon choix de
faire que nous puissions ouvrir flamant
ville parce que si nous avions fermé
flamant ville en 2012
et bien c'était la fin de la filière EPR
comment aurait-il été possible
d'exporter de le père en Chine au
Royaume-Uni on l'avait déjà fait en
Finlande si nous même nous renoncions à
Flamanville donc pour moi l'essentiel
c'était d'ouvrir Flamanville c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit je vais le regret que ce
ne soit pas fait même si ce regret mon
successeur peut l'avoir aussi et mon
prédécesseur également donc mais pour ce
qui concerne fait cela et bien voilà
c'était lié à Flamanville d'une part et
deuxièmement EDF nous fixer des des
règles des procédures et je me suis pas
non plus
gendarmé tous les jours pour dire à quel
moment il faut fermer Fessenheim nous
aurions souhaité par strict respect de
ma parole que ce soit fait à la fin de
de
mon mandat c'est que le Royal a eu
l'obligeance de faire un décret dont on
sait qu'il n'avait pas de valeur
juridique qu'il a fallu donc attendre
quelques années pour que ça puisse se
faire et d'ailleurs sans que Flamanville
de sois ouvert